hello I'm gonna stab a guy remember it
so you don't have to right now I'm in
the laboratory of dr. hack
the master formulas not scientific
formulas not mathematical formulas but
television formulas any TV show that has
a formula that's been repeated over and
over and over he's the guy that came up
with it
watch this Mighty Morphin Power Rangers
LAN teen spike play Patrol they were
monster than giant monster in giant
robot work home improvement Tolman's
crews a neighbor gives advice to me gets
advice wrong but told mins forgiven
anyway scooby-doo it's always the person
in the opening you forgot about
Inspector Gadget Captain Planet
Everybody Loves Raymond everybody
actually hates Raymond he should have
divorced that bitch and her family long
ago if it's a formula that's gotten more
and more popular through its repetition
he's the kind of thought of it and right
now I've hired him to think of an idea
so that I can lazily repeat it over and
over and over and make money beyond my
wildest dreams Eureka Eureka what oh
there you are you Rica get ready to jack
down my latest formula you got it yes
and it's going to make us Millions so
that's wonderful let's hear it
fourteen-year-old girl lacks stupid uses
magical powers that looks slutty and
stupid talking cat tells her how to
fight crime because she's so stupid
surrounds herself with smarter girls
that make her look even more stupid at
Salem Oh what the formula you're
describing is Salem Oh do they have a
villain that keeps attacking the same
town yeah
do they have a tedious romance for the
magic boyfriend yeah does he repeat the
same animation for some hanna-barbera
and it was successful it's one of the
most popular animes of all time mmm
Eureka oh dear well this is embarrassing
um well how about this one
three obnoxiously perfect girls are
raised by three obnoxiously perfect men
in a house in San Francisco and not one
of them is gay well while we're on the
subject why was something as repetitive
as Sailor Moon so successful
I remember when it first aired in
America it was an export from Japan
which i think was originally called
magical girls Quatro bow dance yes not
quite as familiar with anime as
Americans are today a lot of people just
saw it a Speed Racer with tits we didn't
understand that the audience for this
was growing more and more rapid and
whether for its camp enos or actual
enjoyment of the story it was becoming
an underground hit for kids teens and a
creepy guy who fixes your computer so
what is the secret formula and why did
it catch on with so many well let's
start at the very beginning you'll
quickly notice that like many animes the
best parts of the show aren't in the
action the character the story or the
writing it's in the goddamn opening
theme song
not only is the be catchy as hell but
look at this animation look at the
visuals it's like a van Gogh of anime
kid openings if it was even a man go in
it don't ask why I don't care it looks
friggin awesome oh I guess the only
downside is the obvious American edition
like this pointless Star Wars style
scroll yeah because that's what girls
watching this show are really into Star
Wars they go so hand-in-hand I'm
surprised Lucas did release a more
feminine version with Serena doing Darth
Vader did you hear that a new silhoue
video came out I saw it on TV
I didn't battle station plans are not
aboard this ship
oh yeah and no transmissions were made
how can that be my mom finds out you'll
ground me and cut my allowance
skateboard was jettisoned during the
fighting no life-forms were born I can't
believe this oh oh oh am I going to do
we can get ice cream Yesha let's see if
you can spot where else the Americans
made some changes finger so subtle I
doubt you'll ever notice where they
geniusly slip them in yeah
unbelievably natural if you were going
less for action-packed adventure and
more for safe by the Bell credits when
awakened in the
make it on
but you quickly discover in many
respects that is what the show is going
for at first it seems like it's gonna be
a big they'll be it audience insultingly
rushed space battle between cosmic
planet people folk a thousand years ago
our Moon was home to a great
civilization ruled by Queen serenity
then everything changed when the Fire
Nation attacked until the arrival of the
Evil Queen Beryl although her world was
destroyed grim Serenity's last hope was
the power of the Imperium silver crystal
and the crescent moon want only this
crystal and wand can combat the power of
the nega force yeah look show even if
you pretend you have a story that
matters beyond people who see a
high-class meal as a flame and hot
pockets you still had to follow up all
that supposed Evek nests with this
school again yeah I bet you thought this
was going to be a big space opera with
action drama and exotic locations but
nope it's just your common
english-speaking town that has
everything in Japanese for some reasons
Serina I gotta go aren't you forgetting
something dear oh yeah your nose
everyone's forgetting those around here
this is Serena a tipsy Claude who has no
idea that she is one of the
reincarnation of the Sailor Scouts she's
just your everyday gigantic eye blood
Japanese girl who constantly keeps
flunking her exams loud Savina it's just
one lousy test it's not like it's the
end of the world or something you don't
understand I Japanese to me failure is
everything you don't get it Molly if my
mom finds out I flunk that test won't
get to play the new salafi game being
prettiest sin and dumb as cheese she of
course is very popular in school
obtaining all sorts of friends like an
over the top accent with a human
attached to it
that's weird very weird and the awkward
years of dr. and say nose puberty you're
going shopping what's more important
than your grades science of course when
not hanging out with these frightening
adolescent creations she spends most of
her time solving her problems by
intelligently ignoring them and finding
more ways to spend her mother
money I heard about your caste want me
to be your tutor little to that she
needs a trip to them wolves get mine
orphan huh you see new king for vets for
my hair education just gives you
wrinkles she also seems to get in fights
with an attractive boy named Darian
what was that you were saying about
someone totally cool but we can be sure
it isn't you shouldn't you'll be going
home and doing your homework meatball
head Hey that's clearly an insult to
meatballs wow they really seem like
polar opposites and hate each other to
the core what's they hook up and how
tediously long do they drag that out
oh Jesus just mainly the comedic banter
to my office shredder by the way here's
a confusing scene we see her walk by a
poster of a young girl dressed exactly
how she is dressed like it's from a
movie or a show or something I wish I
could be like sailor V she's so
beautiful and smart
something exciting is always happening
in her life not like mine so what a
movie or TV industry got wind of this
idea that coincidentally is exactly the
same as what's going on right now does
that mean that something like
transformers is a true story then
because to be fair my car has been
giving me dirty looks things seem to
change that is the formula set in motion
when a magic cat named Luna arrives and
tells her that she is the reincarnation
of one of the Guardians you are Sailor
Moon and you must fight evil when it
confronts you just repeat after me moon
prism power and of course this gives way
to the famous transformation scene the
tiara the boots the nail polish later
covered by gloves so that was pointless
and of course the miniskirt the Minnie
Minnie Minnie Minnie Minnie Minnie
Minnie Minnie Minnie skirt yep the
costume choice that in no way enables
her to fight better but sure those force
her to squat a lot okay so take out the
fact that's obviously in no way battle
take out the fact that's obviously
fanservice take out the fact that just
like he-man somehow removing more
clothes bizarrely disguises them though
to be fair with both these outfits it's
the face really the first thing you're
going to be looking at take all that
away and just tell yourself this
obviously sexualized transformation that
takes up a solid minute in each episode
happens to a fourteen-year-old girl yeah
forget that for a second engine the
girls in this show are and always have
been 14 years old 14 years old
fourteen-years-old
40 damn at it years old now before any
of you find this incredibly creepy let
me make one thing perfectly clear the
age of consent in many parts of Japan is
in fact 13 years old now you may find it
incredibly creepy and yes there's a lot
of fine print of that law that evens it
out a bit but there's just as much fine
print that evens it back into kinky
territory again for example sex between
13 to 17 year olds can only be done with
other 13 to 17 year olds it's good
however that's only sex groping and job
blowjobs oh whatever else your preferred
imagination can come up with it's all
perfectly legal that's bad however they
have crackdown on human trafficking
force prostitution and other illegal
acts and dangering people in that age
range it's good but that doesn't stop
people from creating kinky
establishments like the sexual
harassment corporation where you pay to
molest girls in school and business sets
and is totally 100% legal
can I go no so um yeah I guess when you
come down to it it is just cultural
differences I mean sexual urges and
young people does start well before a
teen my personal problem is like media
in most cultures it doesn't try to help
younger people understand sexuality but
rather exploits it rather than educate
young people about sex
it's
honestly just easier if we can make
money off of it let's help course all
this talk about Salem um being a sexy 14
year old pinup it's all building up to
one important question given this
information why did I still put her in
the top 11 hottest anime a women list I
didn't know I swear to know I mean look
at the way the drawing man I thought
they were in college or at the very
least late high school would you have
made that guess come on look at the way
they're showing him off I swear officer
I mean audience I had no idea their real
age I mean you might be saying to
yourself Oh what did you grow up
watching the show did you pay attention
to it at all no no I didn't I mean I
want dip I didn't really listen to it
I too was 14 at a time and maybe I
viewed it for different reasons oh my
god this is awful
turn that back on who's that that I did
penis yeah you can talk Oh
penises talk around this age it's the
greatest secret no woman knows about but
wouldn't be the least bit shocked to
discover well despite what a terrifying
discovery this is I'm still not gonna
watch this show it doesn't matter what
you think from now on I'll be calling
all the shots
you're gonna see everything in a whole
new light are you talking about look at
that show again looks damn good now
doesn't it Wow there's more to this show
than I thought oh yeah no I'm a mentally
capable male I won't let my penis call
my decision for me
turn that back on or I'll shoot with a
Sun always shines no I won't excuse me I
need some memories I need to repress
you
Wow I think I've properly erase those
memories they'll be back quiet alright
another groin shot joke
so three no so Serena seems shocked that
she can now suddenly transform this
dream is getting weirder and weirder
I'll never study that hard again though
we're Lee enough doesn't look the least
bit shocked while she's transforming in
fact I bet she'll keep this exact same
calm state every single time she changes
and every villain she's fighting will
quietly wait for her to finish before
actually attacking it's the Japanese way
speaking of which there actually is a
villain in this series known as Queen
Beryl yes because no name is more
terrifying than a wooden container that
can bring me alcohol actually you sure
she's not the hero she uses her evil
minion named Jedi and too obvious to get
energy out of the people of Earth all to
serve the evil realm of the neighbors or
is Luna likes to put it the nega nega
verse the neck of a spell megabus the
negev erson egg of us
how does did I plan to do this by
creating various monsters targeting
people's lust for jewelry pop singers
Fitness and pretty much anything
exploiting the empty shallowness of all
mankind
so naturally Serena is never far behind
often falling for the majority of his
evil plans please get in this evil
device which is in no way an evil device
joke's on you it was an evil device but
once Luna reminds Serena to use her
brain she goes through her pedal Isha's
transformation and is ready to kick ass
or cowers in the corner like a fucking
scaredy cat I don't want to do this
anymore I can't
but the fucking scaredy-cat is braver
than her you must fight this evil
monster all the whole universe could
cease to exist it's time to become
Sailor Moon let's go you have to stand
and fight
be brave
that's exactly what she's doing
she's running from a real fight come on
you idiot don't pussy out pussy up I
think it can also be used that way yeah
well it'll probably surprise no one that
Sailor Moon actually does very little
physical fighting in this show which is
no big shock if she even raises her knee
a centimeter to kick she exposes her
goodies to the world which in many parts
of Japan of course is no big problem
anyway most of the fight scenes require
her being trapped or stuck in something
for probably longer than is needed but
hey anything to save on that
action-packed detailed animation that
we're just going to repeat anyway in
fact the one you'll see most often next
to the transformation sequence is her
using a magic tiara which turns our
enemies to dust or in this case the guy
doing the magic at next door comes to
saber then allowing her to throw her
goddamn tiara you must believe in
yourself Sailor Moon this is Tuxedo Mask
and yes it is painfully obvious who it
really is but please don't tell Serena
she's not very bright others will test
you do not be afraid what a hunky guy
he's so dreamy and not at all like the
other guy who I hate so much thank God
they have nothing in common and are two
completely different people oh hi Clark
get any new pictures of Superman lately
the magic tiara isn't her only enchanted
device though she also has a pen that
can change her into anything
wait what it's a very powerful
transforming tool it turned you into
whatever you want Oh what the fuck is
she using that tiara for I mean they
didn't give any limitations or anything
they said she can change into fucking
anything she wants why doesn't she just
turn around and be like take on the form
of Godzilla
six seasons spared but nope she uses it
just to Don disguises which really
aren't necessary seeing how all you have
to do is throw out a bathing suit on a
napkin over your crotch and apparently
nobody will recognize you and besides we
know she's gonna leave the real fighting
to the other Sailor Scouts oh yeah I
should probably talk about them the
other reincarnations that the scouts are
found over time usually in the exact
same city and often even the exact same
school so maybe Jedi should try is evil
plans and another part of town I mean
it's not like the Power Rangers that can
be many where all this show does is
glorify how lazy Sarina is Sarina a
monster so tacky Tokio how far away is
that about ten miles is just Tokyo
vultures these other sailors are saying
where Mars uses fire Sailor Jupiter who
uses thunder Sailor Venus he uses energy
beams and Sailor Mercury who uses
fucking bubbles their personalities are
about as on par as oh let's say the
Spice Girls no no that's too demeaning
um let's say handsome but to their
credit they are the ones who do most of
the work and they're eventually joined
by another cat named Artemis stop
squabbling then yes even the other
planets over time join the group as well
oh except Pluto um you're not a planet
anymore so um yeah and to answer your
question yes every kid snicker to like
an idiot when they heard there really
was a Sailor Uranus but um actually
things get kind of interesting with her
character seeing how Uranus and Neptune
were cousins in the show but not in the
Japanese version no no in the Japanese
version they were a couple
Oh mocha you know karate
dub I like it that's right straight up
lesbians what was there nothing I said
nothing yeah kind of funny how we can
sex up our 14 year olds all we want but
the idea of them being attracted to
something that don't have a penis
apparently was too much for Americans
back then so just to check okay shine
okay shy come on guys maybe co worked it
into your half-assed PSAs at the end oh
yeah I forgot to mention there's PSAs in
this show
obviously slapped on at the end of each
episode using the same animation they
used before because Laura knows the show
hasn't repeated enough animation already
starving yourself and exercising till
you drop is not a smart way to lose
weight like a car without gas our bodies
can't run without food nutrition food to
say their time fillers is an
understatement half the time they don't
even bother to fill in the dead air they
care so little about it games are nice
especially the ones about food
datings of cool all right
just don't forget about the humor yeah
if they want a more appropriate ending
they go with something like this hey
kids
a lot of time we get angry letters from
your parents because we know our show
makes you dumber so here's our last
minute table scraps to try and teach you
something in the last few seconds we
have brush your teeth or in the case of
the lesbian duo maybe they can do
something like hey kids
you got boys and you got girls big one
and guys that's as far as I got I know
there's more characters and more
villains but I specifically want to
address the repeated formula that got
Sailor Moon popular in the US and why on
earth it actually worked and that
formula as I can figure out is as such
Syrena acts like a selfish idiot
supportive friends pick up her slack
Ferrell rubs crystal ball like a poof
and sends Jedi how to create monster and
or device to obtain energy using a
marketing tool targeted towards Bane
Suburbans one of the scouts discovers
the plan or fall for it herself
transformation takes place via reused
sexually confusing animation Scout or
Scouts are trapped prat mahat seems to
get them out and do nothing else Sarina
never figures out who he is uses her
magic tiara that she should have used
earlier instead of reusing more dialogue
footage destroys villain and goes back
to being an idiot so yeah it's just a
double check again why did this work
perhaps like a lot of other formulas it
knew what to keep familiar and what to
keep changing up in Nura was going to
have a villain but it changed up what
kind of villain it knew it had to
involve an interest or product that
girls wanted to be involved with so it
had a different one each episode there
was always peril that the girls had to
get out of so that you'd feel great by
the end when they finally do keeping the
formula exactly the same but changing up
just the right elements that needed to
be changed so do I enjoy the show fuck
no does I have an ingenious formula fuck
yes is it bad for kids fuck not
rim P well the Serena character is an
annoying airhead I will give her credit
that she does at the very least have a
character it's not one that I like but
at the same time it would have been easy
just to make
a pretty face with no personality but
she clearly does have a personality and
goes to big extremes and I do make her
look strange and bizarre just as much as
they do make it look pretty half the
time and though yeah she can be
self-centered she's never really mean
per se then I guess from what I
understand the character does get
smarter as the series goes on for at the
very least braver
as for sexing up a 14 year old I think
it's weird but I guess there's always
just gonna be cultural differences and
in all honesty we went out much worse
unlike a lot of pop stars and teen
magazines where the artificiality is all
that's there this at least allows girls
the fantasy of being the hero and
actually doing something even if it is
mixed in with that artificiality as well
but I don't know a Serena's dummy
reaction to it all always shows it in
such a good light but the moments where
she fights back and saves the day
is always shown in a good light so have
fun with your little show just keep it
as far away as you can from me I'll let
miss dollar pretty guy remix hello
mr. critic uh dr. hawk thinks he may
have like finished that formula or
whatever way dawg all right critic I
know I messed it with the Sailor Moon
formula when I come up with a formula
that's even better even better
you mean like more successful than
Sailor Moon three times more successful
really yes according to my calculations
this should be the most famous most
profitable formula the world has ever
known
good god doctor half what is it what is
it okay okay
three online performers two male one
female remake movies with the help of a
German cameraman an Irish immigrant
you
the Negev us
hey everybody just giving you the latest
on the IndieGoGo project thanks to
everyone who's been donating and
spreading the word and with that said we
have a new perk it's this wonderful
drawing those done by maro bot and it is
glossy and reflective and shows the
evolution of the nostalgia critic it has
a nice little wall mount only a hundred
them are going to be made and we will
number every single one of them and yes
it will be signed by me as well so click
on the link to see not only how you can
help us out but also get this
collector's item Thanks to everyone
again keep donating and spreading the
word and hopefully we'll reach our goal